thanks so much uh alegre it's really
nice to be here uh for the fall reunion
and uh welcome everyone at least
virtually i hope i get to see you in
person at the next one
um
uh delighted to be able to talk to you
today about what's happening in the
fintech payment space there's kind of a
revolution going on as most of you
probably know
and i want to get your feedback as well
so i'm going to leave a healthy amount
of time at the end
for you to comment or add questions
or give me your your thoughts on on
where this space is going
it's actually very timely for me because
i'm going to be talking
to the gsb trust in the next couple of
weeks about the same topic and i
i'm i'm sure that you could give me some
hints about the sorts of questions that
they'll ask
i've been working on in this area for
the past years uh both on research and
policy work
and this year it seems to be all
all-consuming in terms of the policy
work uh
i'm doing i've been doing some work on
stable coins
on central bank digital currencies
and on china's central bank digital
currency
and i can talk about that project work
but i want to jump into the substance of
the topic
and uh maybe give everyone a sense of
why we're actually discussing this and
uh you know what's wrong with the uh the
current payment system why
why is everybody so excited about
upgrading it
uh
for those of you that are working in
fintech uh you probably know that the
protagonists in this story are always
alice and bob
i think that goes back quite a few years
from the
computer science literature and
cryptocurrencies alice in this uh
situation wants to pay bob the baker
eight dollars for a loaf of bread
uh
and the question is how is she going to
pay bob
now today i'm going to be talking about
general purpose uh payments and not as
much
about the wholesale
interbank
uh
payment system and how that's also going
through a significant upgrade
particularly in security settlement
and cross-border payments but if you
have questions in those areas let's
discuss that because actually i'm quite
passionate about
improvements that are happening in that
area as well i mean for example the
treasury market last year could have
used a substantial upgrade in its
payments and settlement system
and instead we got a very uh significant
problem in that market
but again today we're going to focus on
alice and bob
and most of you know that in most of the
world
alice would typically hand over paper
money or more frequently a credit card
the credit card could be
in an in her mobile phone uh wallet
overlay but it's still typically a
credit card based payment
and it would eventually
flow through
the bank payment rails
like almost all payments in the current
system so alice will send a message
using her
credit card or a mobile phone app a tap
a swish or whatever
and her bank will take eight dollars out
of her account send it through the bank
payment rails
which is pretty complicated actually
and it'll get to bob's bank in a day or
two maybe three but bob instantly gets a
message saying the money's coming
so you can give alice the loaf of bread
uh that experience
uh is working pretty well these days for
alice but she doesn't really know what's
going on in the
guts of the bank payment rails that's
costing bob so much
uh to take that payment
and is causing many other uh costs and
delays that i want to talk about
so these payment rails uh are
illustrated in this schematic
so alice could be customer one of bank
one she's the blue dot at the top left
her bank is bank one b one
and bob's bank is the green dot b3 and
he's maybe customer seven of bank three
and the payment is a deduction from
alice's account at bank one
and then
bank one will credit probably
uh bank three through
the central bank payment system which in
the united states is fed wire and it can
also go through
a private payment system and be merged
and then flow through fedwire
uh as i said this tends to take a long
time and along these payment rails there
are various fees being extracted
if it's a credit card payment
the interchange fees that bob uh has to
pay are actually quite severe in the
united states i want to illustrate that
in this diagram
which comes from
the mckinsey global payments report from
last year
that's a bit of a complicated diagram
i'm not going to go through every
element of it
but i want you to focus on the left
stack that's the north american payment
stack i got the data from the this
report and recompiled it so that it's
easier to see
and you can see that the payment stack
uh for us
the us payment system or the north
american payment system including canada
is heavily uh on the consumer side
meaning consumers are paying a lot in
the united states relative to the rest
of the world
and particularly a lot for credit cards
so the interchange fee for the u.s is
depending on what card you have it's two
dollars to 250 per 100
which is huge actually relative to the
actual cost
europe regulates uh interchange fees for
cards and it's much smaller so it's
about 10 percent of the payment stack in
europe
well it's on average 15 for the rest of
the world
not only is the us payment stack heavily
weighted towards
uh consumer payments meaning
uh
the margin the profit margins are bigger
on the general retail side
it's also just bigger in total dollars
so you can see from the legend at the
top
that u.s payment revenues and that's
basically profits gross of
overhead and other expenses
um constitute about 2.3 percent of u.s
gdp that's huge
uh probably many of you didn't know if
you're not a payments expert but it
costs so much to run the us payment
system
by the way paper cash also costs an
enormous amount and that's not counted
in this diagram paper cash
is also a pretty costly thing uh to do
the rest of the world well let's say
take europe middle east uh and africa
that's 1.7
so the us payment system is a lot more
expensive
and it's not really because it's that
much better uh it's because
there are relatively high profit margins
so uh many have been calling for an
improvement
and uh that's gotten off to a
head start this year because of
china's big news its central bank
digital currency and the fact that china
has already had
extremely uh
efficient mobile payment systems run by
the two large fintech firms
ant group
and tencent
and americans have been kind of
commenters at least in the have been
needling uh the fed and congress and the
administration saying gosh if china can
do this why can't the united states do
this and it's it's gotten into a bit of
a space race
but but let's go to more on the
fundamentals
and talk about
financial inclusion
and i've taken these numbers from the
world bank's global findex
database
and i plotted on the vertical axis
financial inclusion as the percent
of
uh households that actually have access
to the payment system whether through
digital means or otherwise through banks
and you can see that in high income
economies it's typically over 90 percent
in developing economies more like 60
60ish percent
china is quite high
india is quite high
kenya is quite high
uh those those economies china india and
kenya have had the benefit of very
effective mobile payment systems
relative to the rest of the developing
economy and china's
numbers are actually if you updated this
chart to today it's actually much better
moreover the digital payment system in
china is very advanced because of
alipay and wechat pay the two private
services that i mentioned a moment ago
so for example if you're in a city in
china
95
of payments are being made
of digital payments which are most of
them are being made by one of those two
services so they have a virtual duopoly
on
digital payments in
china one of the big pushes in the
united states in congress and in the
administration
is to
change the us payment system so as to
increase financial inclusion there are
about five to seven million households
in the united states that don't have
access to banking
and uh about twice that many that are
relatively weakly banked meaning they
have
uh very costly or inefficient access to
the banking system so they're using
uh
special you know expensive uh paycheck
cashing services and
remittance services that are extremely
expensive
and the united states wants to do
something about that
at the same time the united states is
dealing with
the advent of cryptocurrencies
as you know as you well know
and uh
just recently the president president's
working group is developing a report
on what to do about stable coins which
is a type of cryptocurrency that's
commonly used for making payments i'm
going to get to those in just a minute
so we're on basically on the edge of a
major change in direction
in the united states
and i'm going to talk about the options
at the end but let me just mention
briefly the one option is to
improve the existing bank payment rails
make them more efficient faster cheaper
want more widely available
and accessible to the under
underbanked part of the population
another approach is to let
fintech payment services including
stablecoins
uh compete with banks to make payments
and then a third option is to introduce
a u.s central bank digital currency now
all of those have
a myriad of design
choices or there's a big menu for each
of those and we won't get into all of it
today but i want to engage on some of
those
issues
if you look at vietnam that's a that's a
country that's ripe for leapfrogging all
of these issues like kenya did with
fast efficient mobile phone based
payments so i expect vietnam to
to happen very quickly
india has the benefit of
upi and rdar which in combination have
made bankrail payments extremely
accessible cheap fast and easy to use in
india although that comes with
the need to
for everyone to identify themselves and
sometimes americans don't like to be
putting their identities into a large
data set
what about cross-border payments
oh
i'm not going to talk about that at
length today but if alice who's customer
one of bank one
needs to pay bob in another country
let's say
canada or
argentina
or some other country
then alice needs to alice's bank needs
to find a bank that has correspondent
banking relationships in bob's country
that would be
bank three finding bank four
times those chains uh those food chains
of finding a corresponding banking
relationship extend to three or four
along the chain
and every bank along that chain needs to
check the legality of the payment and of
course needs to check its
to check the
uh
uh uh well to make sure that it gets
paid for the payment as well
so it's very very expensive and
annoyingly uh slow and i'm sure you've
all dealt with that when you've tried to
make a cross-border payment or
remittance payment
if we go the bank-railed route uh we
could do what's called a fast payment
system so the key defining properties of
that
are that it's available 24 7 365
you have near real-time access to the
funds by the recipient of the payment
and there are various design approaches
you you can either do it uh where the
payment is honored immediately but the
banks settle it up later
among themselves and they merge their
payments with each other that's called
deferred net settlement or you can have
straight through real-time gross
settlement which seems to be the way
that most uh fast payment systems are
going the united states
is doing one of those right now
the fed is introducing fed now
which will speed up the bank rail
payments and make them more accessible
although if you want to get a payment
service you still need to go to a bank
to get that service and uh one of the
reasons i believe that the us banking
system is so
inefficient at payments is that banks
don't really have
an incentive to make it so easy to move
your money
and so cheap um that
they're that you that they will
discourage you from using
uh their services in a walled garden
sense
uh and of course uh pay their fees
and keep your money on deposit in their
banks
uh and uh you may or may not know that
u.s
bank deposit rates are extremely low
relative to wholesale rates
uh that's a not very well interested
point that uh u.s bank deposits are very
non-competitive
in terms of paying you
uh
uh what what they're getting for their
money
so um
simply doing a fast payment system like
fednow is a big step forward but i think
in my view it needs to be coupled by
something that causes the banks to
compete harder to offer payments more
competitively
so here are some examples of fast
payment systems
korea was really one of the first
countries to do this
bank of a bank of mexico has spay
which is very successful
sweden has a private system
the united kingdom has introduced a
non-profit utility
singapore has fast payments including uh
cross-border fast payments that it's
introducing
the united king pardon me the european
central bank has its target instant
payment system or tips and as i
mentioned the us is coming online with
fed now probably in the next year and a
half to two years
uh so that's one approach another
approach as i mentioned is stable coins
uh and you can think uh libra but now
it's changed its name to dm and it's
been reorganized
or you can think of coinbase's
stablecoin which is called usdc
these are the two largest stablecoins
uh well tether uh tether is the largest
but um it's not as stable as i don't
include it as really stable although its
price stays near a dollar
the assets backing tether are very
sketchy but here's here's how alice
would get her stable coins uh to make
moments in the united states she would
go to her issuer which could be her bank
or it could be uh
the face facebook which will provide it
through
its issuer of dm
or it could be at coinbase you'll get
online and
uh
load your wallet
uh with usdc
and so in this case the issuer is taking
500 in
in regular money from alice and giving
her 500 stable coins tokens
uh the issuer gives 500 to the trust
that owns the assets backing the stable
coin assuming there are assets backing
it
and then the asset invests that money in
the backing assets which can be bank
deposits they can be treasury bills
commercial paper
uh in the case of tether the backing
assets were quite were basically a black
box until
there was litigation in new york state
that forced them to disclose that it's
mostly commercial paper
and not as
safe perhaps as
u.s authorities might prefer
the trust will
then use the those assets
to authorize the issuer to give the
tokens to alice now she can go out and
send them anywhere uh using a mobile app
or her internet uh
uh online
and uh make payments
or do peer-to-peer
pay for a cup of coffee whatever she
wants
now the authorities in the united states
are quite concerned on a number of
grounds first
will the assets backing these tokens be
solid
second
will the
all of the money coming out of other
coming out of the banks cause a problem
for the banks
not having enough deposits i'm actually
not worried about that one
another issue is will the
blockchain on which the tokens are
issued
be stable operationally stable and up 24
7 365.
if a lot of americans start depending on
stable coins the authorities are worried
about that
so those are on the worry side on the
positive side uh the advent of stable
coins may provide a lot of new
opportunities to make new kinds of
payments like
doing internet of things
smart contracting programmable payments
and they may also cause more competition
for banks which i think would be a very
good thing
the other
element of the payment revolution that's
going on globally is central bank
digital currencies or cbdc's
and in this case
alice and bob simply could have an
account at the central bank
no they would have an account of the
central bank in effect and alice's
message to pay bob would simply mean
eight dollars moves out of alice's
account at the central bank and into
bob's account so that's very quick and
easy it would be super cheap
it would in principle be
available to anyone anywhere on a simple
on a simple mobile phone app or on the
internet
by any other device and make payments
quite simple although there are some
downsides first of all maybe you don't
want the central bank having to look
after every single
account in the united states and the fed
might be worried about that secondly
the central bank is going to have to
check on the legality of all these
payments that's a big operation
moreover in order to do that
central bank needs to keep tabs on
everyone and that's a potential concern
for those worried about privacy so this
trade-off between privacy
and legal payments
uh is
causing a lot of concern in terms of the
design side of this
and i won't go into any details but i
hope you asked me about that later
i'll take one of the central banks
that's investigating this and just
discuss what they view as
the benefits of or objectives of
exploring central bank digital
currencies so one is
making sure that you're not relying on a
flaky or sketchy
payment provider so resilient payments
i'll skip to three so you're supporting
competition efficiency and innovation
meeting future payment needs
improving the availability and usability
of central bank money addressing the
consequences of a decline in paper cash
which is an issue what what do you do
once there's no no more paper money i
went to sweden recently and like they
wouldn't take my paper
swedish kroner to pay my hotel bill
uh
and then uh provide a better method for
making cross-border payments better
faster cheaper
when we do see uh
central bank digital currencies in
practice they're mostly going to be
done this way the way that china is
doing it so when alice
gets her
central bank digital currency in china
which is going to be called e-c-n-y
that means electronic cny cny is the
foreign exchange symbol for
chinese renminbi
alice will get it from a bank most
likely her payment service provider
and she'll send the message to her bank
to tell the central bank to deduct 80
remnb
from her account
put it in bob's account bob will get a
message from his payment service
provider
that the money has been paid and he'll
give alice to bread and that'll all
happen in a second or two
and by the way china's cbdc is not done
as a cryptocurrency or on a blockchain
it's a central database management
system
and uh they're doing that in order to
get sufficient speed throughput of about
300 000 transactions a second although i
think the cryptocurrency experts will
figure out how to do it that fast pretty
soon
now china's not doing this on its own as
i mentioned banks are helping also
telephone companies providing the apps
and software
and thin taxi payment service providers
the traditional ones in china wechat pay
and alipay
and many others uh in the private sector
and this is like a likely private public
partnership in the united states as well
although in the u.s it's still only at
the research stage the mit and the
federal reserve bank of boston are
collaborating on research led by dr neha
narula at mit
but
for now it's just research there's no
development many other countries though
are developing
central bank digital currencies you can
see in this chart from the bank for
international settlements
significant increase
in the last few years
and the fraction of
in the number of central banks working
on cbdc's
some of them are only doing wholesale
some are doing general purpose most are
doing both
and uh
most of them are still in the stage of
experiments research proof of concept
and only a few are in development
as i mentioned
most cases you're going to have this
hybrid system where alice doesn't deal
directly with the central bank
she she deals directly with her payment
service provider and you need to make
sure that the app that alice gets for
her phone is completely interoperable
with the app that bob is using
and that means very strong standard
setting
so it's a it need the design uh
implications are need take they take
time to develop the privacy
uh the privacy side of it collect
securing the data securing the
resiliency of the system operationally
against outages
uh and also something to check uh on
anti-money laundering
uh and other illegal payments
all of that needs to be designed in a
place like the united states
here are some major cbdc developers and
as i mentioned china has already done it
officially the release comes next year
but there are already
hundreds of millions of
people well over 100 million people in
china have used it
and up for a large volume of payments
sweden has been doing this for
development work for some time korea
nigeria bank of canada i'm a canadian by
the way
canada has said
we're not we're going to develop it now
but we're not going to release it until
we feel that it's really necessary and
really necessary means
maybe paper money uh will not be any
longer acceptable or maybe a private
cryptocurrency that we don't want to
have
uh in our payment system is getting too
much traction so we'll try to head it
off
with a cbdc
i've listed some readings at the bottom
[Music]
if you want to get in touch with me at
any time and ask for ask questions on
the side or
ask for some of these readings let me
know
you can always reach me here at the
business school
i'm getting close to the end of my
prepared remarks so i hope you're
you're getting ready with your questions
i'm looking forward to your comments and
your questions
so what are the policy options uh and
let's say for the united states by the
way one of my projects
uh
with dr elizabeth economy we're
co-directing an expert group of
uh 27 leading experts from
national security
economics finance
policy former government officials
several
former members of the national security
council former undersecretaries of the
treasury
former head of the central bank some a
lot of top experts
and our policy group is attempting to
advi or provide at least
a roadmap for policy to the united
states government
and we're focusing in particular on the
implications of china's cbdc a lot of
people are worried
that china may
somehow take in uh take advantage of its
central bank digital currency to get
ahead of the us
in uh
in a way that the us might
need a plan to to deal with and among
the plans are simply improve the us
payment system but also provide a
central bank digital currency that would
give the united states a leading
position internationally
in how central bank digital currencies
are being used
and at this point there's some
disagreement among the leadership of the
fed
about whether a cbdc development project
would be a good idea or not with some
governors of the fed saying there's no
need it's a solution in search of a
problem
and one central bank governor saying
that she can't get her head around the
idea of not developing a central bank
digital currency
so u.s policy well one approach as i
mentioned you could use regulation and
fast payment infrastructure to get a
more open and competitive bank rail
payment system something that allows
entry
by fintech firms
and
um basically reduces the walt garden
effect around the banks
and fast payments of course providing
the operational foundation a second
approach is to allow or even encourage
compliant private stable coins subject
of course
to the um
regulations that you would need
including interoperability so that
people could exchange payments even if
they didn't have exactly
uh the correct apps
a third approach
is to encourage not payment not
necessarily stable coins but other
fintech payment service providers to
enter the bank rail payment systems and
they could do that if they were to get
accounts at the federal reserve
again it would be subject to strong
compliance
and interoperability standards and then
finally the kind of a nuclear option
because it's such a big deal and it's so
disruptive to banking and the payment
landscape is to introduce a general
purpose
central bank digital currency and when i
testified to the senate banking
committee this summer
uh i said you should develop in my view
a central bank digital currency now
should begin developing it now because
it takes five or six years at least
before you'll have a cbdc that
you'll you will know its costs and
benefits and if you wait until you think
it's necessary
it'll take you five years from that
point
um
but i'm hoping that
option one
could be enough so that it doesn't have
to be
run by the central bank
i fear however that a cbdc may be
necessary and as i said i'm recommending
that
the united states pursue that
immediately rather than putting it off
the fed is about to release a white
paper that's been delayed twice now
um because i think it's still making up
its mind on whether or at least what its
stance should be the white paper is only
going to be a discussion of costs and
benefits on a request for comment
but uh um i i think the vet is
uh
genuinely uncertain about whether it's a
good idea and it's waiting for
uh
leadership from congress and the
administration on this
so with that i want to turn it back to
uh every all of you i feel like i've
been running a monologue here
uh
i wanna i wanna hear what you have to
say i see some chats
yes we've had a lot of questions come in
can we start off by setting a little bit
of baseline knowledge for our audience
of what uh is the difference between
cbdc's and general cryptocurrency
uh such as bitcoin and how blockchain
works
sure
uh well a cbdc doesn't uh doesn't tell
you whether it's a cryptocurrency
meaning it's uh on a blockchain trades
as like a tokenized
money or whether it's just a central
database management system like the one
that china has
uh a cryptocurrency as you know is
typically an asset uh which is called
the currency but in some cases like
bitcoin it's
you can call it a currency but it's an
extremely volatile uh asset it's only
used to some extent to make payments
its other uses are
mostly related to speculation
uh
it has the advantage that it doesn't
require a trusted third party and that's
a very cool design
and other cryptocurrencies these are uh
permissionless cryptocurrencies
uh also have this advantage that they
don't require a trusted third party
everybody is democratically just
transferring money on the same
blockchain
uh which is uh you know in the cloud
somewhere
uh
a stable coin is a type of
cryptocurrency
whose price is intended to be
constant in terms of fiat money like one
for one ideally
uh and right now stable coins are being
used mainly as a medium of exchange in
the cryptocurrency space
they're not yet been being used much for
general
payments in the in the u.s retail
markets
but they could be
uh so that's you know that's what i
would say uh in answer to that question
but i'm happy to take a follow-up
well related to that we have somebody
asked could you comment on the valuation
approach for non-stable cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin
okay so it's a bit like gold uh in fact
larry summers recently said that's the
new gold
in the sense that it's worth whatever
people are willing to pay for it hoping
that they can sell it later to somebody
else who will pay more for it
and i think that characterizes most
cryptocurrency investments
uh and they are getting very popular
uh
i read a report yesterday by one of uh
stanford's former phd students michael
schwartz who's the chief economist at
microsoft who feels that there's a
tremendous amount of potential growth in
the total market value of
cryptocurrencies
not only for speculation
but because
people want a place to store money that
they don't want anyone else to know
about so right now they're using paper
100 bills or or paper 500 euro notes or
a thousand swiss franc nodes and that's
pretty cumbersome and it's hard to
transfer those
but it's working pretty well for the
people that want to keep their their
wealth in a private form and that would
include a lot of criminals
uh but other than storing wealth
privately which is a bit illicit in many
cases or very illicit or making illegal
payments
uh
bitcoin and many other currencies are
used
uh for speculative purposes and i think
that's the majority of the transactions
are people hoping bitcoin will go up and
they buy it or they think it might be
going down so they sell it it's
extremely volatile
as far as as valuing it um
as i said if you can put a price on gold
then you can put a price on
bitcoin pretty well
what are the implications of this of all
of this on money laundering
yeah and let me couple that with a
question i see is bitcoin really private
and so let's couple that with the issue
of money laundering or ransom payments
which happened recently when the u.s u.s
oil pipeline was shut down
uh and in demand
by uh a
cyber attack and the ransom was paid in
bitcoin
so uh
money laundering ransom payments and
privacy well
it's not private at all everybody can
see the blockchain everybody has full
vision
of bitcoin on the blockchain
but of course you don't have the name of
the person like doesn't say daryl duffy
has
212 bitcoin
uh it just gives the uh
isp
and so people can track what i'm doing
by that
it turns out that the us authorities are
starting to get pretty good at tracking
uh payments of bitcoin on the blockchain
and they actually tracked down the
the ransom
payments and told the
uh well basically got back several
million dollars of the ransom and more
recently a lot of bitcoin was stolen
uh from
uh
the blockchain and the
the the thieves were forced to give it
back because they were called out and
everybody knew
uh you know
where those bitcoin were going in effect
and we're tracking them so they
basically gave most of it back so it's
not private paper money if you really
want to hide your wealth is much more
effective except that you have to then
guard it uh in a much more expensive way
and it's hard to move around the world
what would back the us stable coin and
what is the estimated cost reduction
from the two percent of gdp
okay uh
well
uh let's talk about the backing it's the
same backing as paper money
so when the central bank issues paper
money
um there is there is no backing it's
just an iou uh so it says the fed owes
you if you have a hundred dollar bill if
that owes you a hundred dollars
so you could uh
use that hundred dollars if you got
enough dollars you could use it to buy
from the fed treasury securities through
your bank or something like that
but there's nothing in the sense that
there's no money in the there's no gold
in a vault or
physical assets backing it it's an iou
just like when you have money in your
bank
it's not there's no stack of coins or or
anything else sitting in the bank
waiting for you to come and collect it
it's simply an iou
and when you call the iou the bank says
okay we'll pay you
and we'll cash in something else to do
that
so almost all money in the world now is
in the form of an iou one way or the or
another and almost none of it has
backing many years ago
uh fiat currencies like the dollar and
most currencies in fact had gold backing
but that was abandoned the supply of
gold became too limited and in any case
the price of gold is too volatile to be
a backing the monetary authorities are
able to keep the price of fiat currency
reasonably stable us inflation has been
between zero and two percent
for about three decades uh so it's
with some ups and downs right now it's a
bit more than two but
fiat currencies are very stably priced
so you don't need to worry about the
backing for the dollar
maybe if you were in zimbabwe or some
other country who has a history of
very very high inflation you might be
worried that there's nothing backing
your paper money so maybe you should
trade it for
something else like a different fiat
currency or gold
hi this is zac from singapore so i want
to really ask to you the question about
the the regulator and the regulation uh
because recently some of the government
language launched before and the
singapore government also the central
bank just launched the payment token
license also try to address some of the
aml and
anti-money laundering issue here so
what's your view on the regulator what's
the regulator role here for the
the regulating all those different
currency
the regulator really should be running
the show because money
money is a public good it's it's like
you know the internet
it's it's like the internet it's like
the uh
the highway system the air traffic
control system these are all public
goods they're utilities that we all
depend on and that any one firm or
individual doesn't really internalize
all the benefits of keeping
money and the payment system stable and
highly efficient so the government
really or regulators really have a key
role in deciding
on the design of the payment system
and how to regulate its use now that
said the private sector such as yourself
zach
uh you're the entrepreneurs that are
uh working within the rules that the
regulator sets i know ravi mendon at the
monetary authority of singapore he's an
excellent regulator and i'm sure he and
the monetary authority of singapore are
very effective at working with firms
like yours singapore is one of most of
the one of the most advanced
treatments of fintech payments of any
country in the world it's way ahead of
many other countries as you know you
have
your fast
payment system which is very effective
and singapore has a cross-border fast
payment system now and moreover uh
singapore is considering
ahead of most countries what carefully
what to do about central bank digital
currencies and i've seen some of their
work on that
so you you can be
i think very confident that your country
is
doing a great job
from the regulatory standpoint and
making sure that
citizens in singapore have access to
efficient payments that are safe
uh so my question uh tags on to the last
one and that is uh what are your
recommendations for keeping the
regulatory bodies
uh relatively
unpoliticized because now what we're
talking about is who regulates
and what's their agenda
so because we're talking about things
that have massive global implications as
opposed to the typical geographically
central
uh fiat currency
yeah uh bernard i totally agree with
your comment
you wanna you want the regulators to be
non-political and also aligned so they
need to have a plan
and that and that plan is up first up
the congress which authorizes the
administration to design the plan
uh and the united states is behind and
congress and the administration have
agreed we are behind they're very
explicit
they said they have said
we should have already
known what to do about stable coins and
cryptocurrencies but now we're catching
up that's basically what's happening and
you have a little bit of it's not just
the regulator in the us it's many
regulators so the securities and
exchange commission under chair gary
gensler is taking a lot of action
uh under the authorities
of the securities regulations
other regulators are
uh
taking a bit more time to be thoughtful
about it uh the fed is in my view being
so thoughtful that they're falling
behind even further
and they need to move along i've had
notes from people in in congress i won't
name names
uh that have suggested that the fed
should be moving along faster on this
and uh chair powell of the fed has said
he's genuinely uncertain whether the us
needs a central bank digital currency
uh and as i mentioned several governors
of the fed are kind of
in in pointing in different directions
on this so the fed needs to move along
as well but i think the fed is waiting
for guidance from the administration
so i think president biden's
administration
will will be providing guidance on this
issue in the near future and then the
fed will move it will release its white
paper get comments and decide what to do
will they allow
stable coins
uh
don't know will they promote development
of cbdc don't know
my suspicion is though that they will
try to do better with the bank rail
payment system and maybe they will make
the case
we don't need all that new stuff uh what
we need to do is improve
the old stuff
uh put in
uh fast braille
fast bank rail payments do better job on
competition with banking
and uh and let the banks run this uh
they
they have done a reasonable job on any
money laundering they've done a
reasonable job of protecting your
privacy
in my view they've done an unreasonably
bad job on competing with each other to
give you good services at low prices
and to innovate with smart smarter
payment systems and as a result you know
here we are today uh
way behind in the united states every
economist and every regulator that i've
spoken to agrees
that the united states is further behind
than any other major country in this
area
i'm high so um it's mark louis and uh
professor duffy i will confess this is
an area that i'm still trying to get my
head around so i may have some
fundamental misunderstandings of how
some of this works
but to me as central bank digital
currency is just an electronic form of
another fiat currency like a paper
currency
um and so in my mind
notwithstanding the fact that there's a
lot of design issues and regulatory
issues and whatnot it seems to me and
this is you know an editorial combat
from somebody that's not very well
informed to be the natural extension of
what the fed does in terms of the paper
money in the system um
so i find it attractive or at least
interesting from that perspective
um the issue really is what it does to
the existing commercial banks both in
the u.s and elsewhere because
as a consumer or as a businessman i
could see that if i was able to transact
at the central bank um as as much fun as
the guys at chase and wells fargo are um
i would probably they would become
disintermediated in probably less than
10 seconds
and so i guess the question that i've
got for you and i'm not really sure it's
the right question is
what does this do to the commercial bank
infrastructure if you will
um
what does it do to the profit model of a
commercial bank to their balance sheets
and
there are other values that commercial
banks
have in the economy in terms of
conducting monetary policy and
multipliers and
um all sorts of other things um
and so it it seems like a uh unfolding
but it seems like such a a radical
reordering of the financial system that
i just have trouble getting my head
around it anyway i'm not sure where the
question is in there but i just i'd love
to hear your comments well uh mark
you've asked you've nailed it that's the
64 trillion dollar question that you've
nailed
we have a weak payment system because
banks don't have incentive to make it
better
and the if the alternative is everything
is done at the central bank
that disrupts the entire banking system
and so you've got these two extremes
both of which are not that attractive
actually because you know i mean central
banks are very effective at what they do
but they're not noted
for facing every single citizen in the
country with retail services
and they might mess that up they might
mess up your data security
uh they might
uh have an operational outage and oops
nobody can pay anybody
so we don't we don't want to go whole
you know whole hog all the way to the
extreme
the midpoint uh and if you go the other
way of course if you just say well we
don't want to do that we'll just let the
banks continue as they are that's also
terrible because as i mentioned we have
a
decrepit payment system if you ask me
and i think most people would agree with
that so what's the happy medium the
happy medium is
either
regulate the banks harder for
competition allow entry uh
by fintech firms or force banks to
compete harder and open up
banking services at lower cost
or introduce a central bank digital
currency that's not the extreme version
that i just described it's a version in
which
the banks
and other payment service providers are
facing you they are designing the
software
that you are using on your mobile phone
up to uh
up to a uniform standard of
interoperability and they are
responsible for monitoring your payments
for legality and protecting your data
just as we have today in terms of
monitoring
so that i i would i would guess that the
u.s government is going to figure this
out and they're going to take one of
those two approaches a
fix the current bank rail payment system
or b
introduce a hybrid system in which the
banks are still running everything but
you're using central bank money
and going back to your question mark
even that will be disruptive to the
banks because
if you're using central bank money a lot
that means you're not using your bank
deposits to make payments
banks will have to go out and get their
funding
on the wholesale funding market to a
greater extent the cost of their funding
will go up bank profitability will go
down that's a commonly agreed thing
and then we need to think about will
that affect loan provision
will banks then not want to make as many
loans
because now their deposit funding is
more costly and there's a massive debate
going on
in that area as well where there are
some that uh that say well banks will
become less profitable but they
they weren't offering any loans at a
loss uh so they're going to continue
making the same loans that they were
already making
and others say well you don't get it i
mean i'm one of the former camp
uh others will say you don't get it um
if you cause banks to have to pay more
for deposits and compete harder
they'll they'll be uh less they'll be
more reluctant to make loans
so uh so
that all has to be sorted and it's no
wonder the fed is having trouble making
up its mind but it's going to have to
make up its mind pretty soon because
not only is it
is there a benefit to making a choice
everybody now is commenting and the fed
is under pressure uh the government and
therefore the administration is under
pressure
uh to to resolve what's the best course
to take
uh and this has all changed if you ask
someone five years ago in the government
should we introduce a cbdc they would
say well not really because everything
is there's nobody nobody really needs
that now everybody in the government is
saying
oh gosh that's a really tough question i
don't know but we should we should uh
try to solve that right away
yeah hi professor duffy uh my question
follows on mark's question a bit on the
big picture macro economic effects of
having a central bank digital currency
and i'm wondering
from your view
what are all of the other areas where
having uh almost instantaneous transfer
of money is going to be disruptive
because for example in the securities
markets we have two t plus two
settlement right now uh lots of security
fails and of course that just moderates
the velocity of money by having this
two-day settlement uh inside of the
securities markets and i'm and you think
about how households have their
paychecks going into the banks and then
that also mitigates sort of how fast
they can be transferring money so what
are your views on having
uh reasonably constructed central bank
currency as you had said either through
banks or directly
what would macro economists need to
factor in that is a new world in that
situation
well that's uh
a super good question and it's another
one that's uh fostered a huge amount of
debate
so
it sounds like you might have been
working on wall street or you might be
working on wall street
uh it's securities regulator yeah okay
well then you know the famous uh saying
on wall street that nothing good happens
between the time at which a trade is
made and the time at which it settled
in other words uh
if you can settle trades faster because
then you're not exposed to counterparty
risk and moreover the money that you
have tied up and the securities that you
have tied up until the settlement is
done are trapped uh or committed
and there and you want to get those
released as soon as possible so that you
the system is more liquid and efficient
the the counter argument to that
is first well if we do instant
settlement using blockchain technology
which is now possible
then everybody that wants to buy
securities will have to have the money
lined up before they make the trade
because it's going to settle instantly
so you got to be ready
uh and the other the other uh
uh the other concern is uh that you
wanna make sure that the blockchain
architecture is really really solid
and uh i suspect that that problem can
be circumvented
last march as since you're in securities
you know that settlement failures soared
in just three weeks last march three
weeks alone
1.5 trillion dollars of treasury
securities transactions
were not settled on time they failed
uh and that was a uh
really uh a light bulb went off in
washington and said we got to do
something about the settlement system in
our securities markets and i've been
advocating
first central clearing
so that you're not depending on your
counterparty directly of a clearinghouse
that guarantees the payments
and then investigating a blockchain
settlement that would allow faster
settlement and i've been uh working or
writing a paper with digital asset
holding which is a blockchain settlement
company
uh that a wall street firm fintech
startup that's doing wholesale security
settlement
uh and you can find the paper on my
website
and cvdc if it's done in a blockchain
would
accelerate that because it would make it
possible
uh to do
instant settlement on the blockchain
if you secure a tie if you if you
tokenize both the securities and the
money
and you could do it with cbdc or you
could do it with a private stable coin
it doesn't have to be retail could be
just wholesale and a lot of countries
are doing just wholesale switzerland
uh canada singapore a number of
countries are exploring just wholesale
cbdc's because of this issue
although there's no major breakthroughs
yet
all right yeah
nice nice to see you again yes i
remember you from my class good to see
you
good to see you yeah um yeah
as you know i was working from the uh
cryptocurrency sensitivity
infrastructure for a while now so what i
see from my uh point of view like like
from crypto ball so right now there is
emerged like uh kind of meta banking
thing it's when the people
earn money and receive the money in
their uh crypto space and what do you
think like so this means that there will
be opportunity for
something like financial institution
that works not under one jurisdiction
but kind of metal layer above all the
jurisdictions
and uh what do you think like uh in
different countries the governments they
will fight it they will adopt it they
will kind of plug in or or maybe they
will create their own kind of meta
financial institution so what's uh
what's the plan
well uh china is going to block it the
united states is still deciding what to
do for those of you that are not
following this what igor is talking
about is is called defy decentralized
finance and
almost everything that you can do in
traditional finance uh
which is called tread fi now
you can also do
in the cryptocurrency space using um
blockchain-based systems so you can
borrow money
you can uh invest in cryptocurrencies
you can make
payments
uh you can sign derivatives securities
options forwards futures
all kinds of
basically all the major things that are
happening in traditional
uh securities markets like christina was
talking about and money and banking you
can now do
in the crypto space recently
the securities and exchange commission
of the united states threatened
uh to sue coinbase
over its proposed lending of
cryptocurrencies on
on its service
and uh
coinbase initially bridled at the
idea that what they were doing was
subject to sec regulation
but uh generally speaking it's not a
good idea to
go up against the securities and
exchange commission and and coinbase has
backed down and they're going to comply
they're not going to release their
lending cryptocurrency lending program
but off the you know outside of the
regulated sphere as igor suggested
globally um most of these activities are
not regulated and they're going to be
brought into regulation country by
country and my suspicion is that the
united states
will will say something like the
following
okay
you can do all this stuff because we
already let banks and securities firms
and
uh and others do it but you have to meet
exactly the same standards so you have
to have full compliance you have to do
full anti-money laundering you have to
do full auditing of all of your
customer accounts for
what what christina may know is a 15 c 3
requirement so that you're protecting
your customer account money you have to
do everything the whole nine yards of
regulation for banking and securities
and there may be additional regulations
laid on top of that that will mitigate
uh some of the concerns associated with
an anonymity or
illegal payments
so i would anticipate igor
if you have friends that are doing this
that they'll be able to continue to do
it
um but they're they're going to be
required in the united states and in
some other countries
to meet a whole the whole gamut of very
very
rigorous regulation
uh
right now if you ask staplecoin
developers like dm what they most want
they most want to know what are the
regulations going to be
they say fine bring it on
but tell us what the regulations are
going to be and then we can make our
business plans and get money and raise
capital and innovate but until we know
exactly what the landscape this
regulatory landscape will look like it's
very difficult for us
to move forward and that's why the
united states needs to move
move on this pretty quickly and the
administration
and the uh and the regulators are moving
uh
and uh they're meeting uh it's a hot
item in washington everybody that i know
and
all of my contacts and the agencies tell
me that it's
a very hot uh issue in washington right
now partly brought on by china the
united states does not want to get left
behind
i think it's enough i forget about china
i mean that's important but it's enough
just to address the u.s payment system
to get this right
thank you for the very perceptive
questions uh all the questions that you
asked were fabulous and i'll go through
the chat if you'll send it to me
absolutely thank you to everybody for uh
joining us today and i hope you enjoy
the rest of uh reunion and virtual
alumni week thanks